le grand rush de la rentrée n'a pas
encore commencé mais les files sont déjà
longue
or en temps d'épidémie le magasin veut
limiter la foule pour la première fois
un système de tickets donc mise en place
nul besoin de se presser avant d'être
appelé est un qr code permet aux
possesseurs de smartphones de se
promener dans le centre
jusqu'à ce que leur tour arrive ce qu'on
cherche à ce que les clients puissent
rester le moins longtemps
malheureusement pas de commerçants cdo
de dire ça marche on veut on veut faire
en sorte qu'ils attendent le moins
longtemps dans le magasin évitez
l'immobilisation donc là on a une petite
files d'attentes qui serait beaucoup
plus grande en temps normal exactement
c'est une petite file d'attenté puis on
oublie pas qu avec la distanciation
obligatoire de mettre ou un médecin
quand les fils sont beaucoup plus
longues
auparavant quand on avait des files qui
prenait 3 personnes à gaza peut-être 30
m aujourd'hui une file de trois
personnes c'est 60 m donc cette année ce
qui commande les livres et fournitures
scolaires et paye sur internet sont trop
offre plus nombreux que l'an dernier en
magasin l'effectif a été doublée pour
préparer ses commandes
alors là je vais préparer une liste de
second pour un élève de seconde
on a également des livres de poche donc
ça se trouve au rayon littérature
également quelques petits matériaux en
papeterie un job de deux mois bienvenue
pour cet étudiant on arrive à gérer les
collègues nous aide aussi
on a beaucoup de commandes à traiter
beaucoup de commandes de clients qui
viennent les récupérer ne récupérer du
coup ce qu'on fait c'est que comme on
est bien organisé on arrive à trouver
assez rapidement et surtout ce qui fait
la différence c'est qu'il ya certains
livres qui sont pas disponibles qu'on
peut mettre en commande spéciale pour
eux
chaque jour une cinquantaine de liste
sont ainsi préparés et livrés ou bien
remise en main propre et efficace rapide
est ce que ça vous rassure aussi par
rapport au fait que vous avez croisé -
demont moins longtemps
ah oui tout à fait oui oui oui c'est
beaucoup plus rapide j'ai pas du tout à
patienter je suis arrivé tout de suite
j'ai été prise en charge les bouquins je
les ai eus en même pas 10 minutes et
puis je suis déjà repartir cette année
le kobe d'autres incidents sur le
secteur certains fournisseurs ont
malheureusement mis la clé sous la porte
et certains livres scolaires auront du
retard
effectivement quelques délais de un peu
plus long que d'habitude notamment par
le fait qu'il ya eu aussi des retards
dans les impressions des ouvrages des
imprimés orient a été fermée pendant le
coup vide ils ont été aussi en chômage
partiel il ya eu des reprises avec des
effectifs plus faible est offert mesure
bien la machine se remet en marche et ça
a un impact aussi pour nous aux antilles
sachant qu'on a aussi les délais de
transport qui font comme mais
malheureusement on reçoit pas les
ouvrages en même temps que les
métropolitains
ces prochains jours les livres les plus
attendus sont ceux de terminale années
de réformes tous les manuels changeant
la rentrée donc pas moyen de se fournir
d'occasions